um yeah so I guess it's been a long day
so I there's been no code in this slide
and it's maybe not your average data
science talk but it's a bit different so
maybe that's interesting so python vs
orangatang who everybody knows this guy
right his name is Wally you see I was so
Diaz Wally but you google the picture
it's Waldo interesting Swiss border yeah
well Meghan airing so the whole point
being you know where where's where's
waldo so if anybody can see Walter here
i'll eat my shoes well oh yeah he's
right there so you know you got some
character older you go these cluttered
ski scene and you have to kind of figure
out where he is that's kind of the game
so I was kind of faced with the same
problem but except instead of Waldo I
was instead of some kind of cartoon
scene I was faced with jungle and figure
out where is the orangutan does anybody
see you're hanging in time well actually
there's none here but you get the point
so just maybe a bit of background why am
i doing why am I talking about rankings
or just just maybe out me personally you
know my background I come from a
computer science machine learning kind
of this kind of environment however I
was like physical tangible things I was
more drawn towards you know big machines
and engineering and aerospace and that
kind of thing but I also I like given my
background I like to do something useful
something you lack of a better word
something use or something to contribute
something to society also so I've done
quite a bit of work in the humanitarian
of conservation doing and you'd bring
these things together robotics becomes
an interesting topic because it kind of
you can merge these three different
things then again some people may know
me from the algorithms or the machine
learning meetups which which I organized
anyway also just a personal pet project
mine at the moment is I'm trying to
build a little robot that can go clean
up litter but it's not easy but if
anybody is interested I'd love to talk
about this and actually all the stuff
I'm doing now is I'm going to talk about
today's stuff i've i've done over the
past year or so when i was working with
the drone company but now actually since
two weeks I've now switched hats ah now
I'm working I'm working for ox partyka
working on driverless cars and thing
so maybe that's a talk for for next year
but again i'm almost interested to talk
to people if you want to chat about this
anyway orangatang so long story short
i've been working with international
animal rescue who are a fairly large
animal rescue charity and they do they
work with the number of species but in
particular they have a couple of large
orangutang centers and so Ranga tangs
are endangered species and there's a big
issue with habitat destruction so you
have animals who have been found in
parkville who've been as in he chased
out of the forest by palm on plantations
were cutting down the forest upon palm
oil because they're look so cute people
like keeping them as pets but often you
know tied to a chain for ten years at a
time all you know there there's a listen
some sad stories there but and hence you
have various charities like
International Rescue who try to take in
animals that have been abused as pet so
rescue them from Palma plantation etc
and then try to rehabilitate them and
best they can and release them back into
the wild that's kind of the idea but the
the problem is then okay fine you you've
invested a whole bunch of time a whole
bunch of money and it's shocking how
much time and money goes into this into
rehabilitating a particular orangutang
and let's say he's the ages right and
he's healthy enough etc you can release
him back into the forest but the whole
point of releasing them back in the
forest is that they survive you know a
full healthy life so they live up to
their you know the 40 50 years or
whatever the problem is you release the
orangutan how do you know he survives
six weeks to months eight years how do
you know he's still around how you know
he's doing all right you know it's it
jungle so this is a problem how do you
want to track the animal to actually
check up on him say okay is he doing all
right okay no you seems to have at Rob
some trouble less taking back in or
whatever so this is the fundamental
problem and what people refer to as the
post release monitoring phase and so the
overall goal is you know you have an
animal you've released it and you want
to kind of monitor what the health and
the well-being is of that particular
animal and this is this is very
intensive it's essentially 24-7 for the
first two three months and this then
tapers off over 23 years now different
charities manage this differently but
this is the case I was working with so
you can imagine for 23
twenty-four/seven you know it's
essentially you're trudging through the
swamp in the forest waving mountain ski
toes and trying to find these animals
it's not fun it's very human intensive
and also you know okay fine you follow
them 24-7 for three months so you know
where they are but then you haven't seen
them for a month or a week where where
is he how do you find how do you find
them not not tricky now so you need some
kind of tracking system and there's
different elements to this there's
electronics is the actual tracking
electronics is how you somehow attach
some kind of tracker to the animal then
there's how do you collect the data how
do you transmit it and then how do you
interpret the data and now I you know I
don't have time to talk about everything
but these are the fundamental bits and
there's interrelated and there's all
kinds of trade-offs is worth thinking
about attachment though because you know
often people say well this is a solved
problem if you're tracking elephant or
you're tracking rhino or you even even
pigeons you can buy colors you know put
a color around the neck of a cheetah or
or even little colors around pigeons
feet or things problem with the rang a
tang since they're very clever and very
strong and the physiology such it's not
obvious where you would attach anything
you couldn't you think okay maybe put a
collar around the neck but the problem
is especially the males they have these
cheek pads so you know no no you can't
put anything about nekkid it would
obstruct with their physiology that
doesn't work and also they don't really
have a neck you could often produce
slide it over I think like and maybe you
know an anklet or a bracelet but they
are they're very flexible hands you just
slide it straight off and also you'd
want something that you know it had you
know you attach it the first thing we'll
do they'll stop biting and pulling it
and chewing it you know again they're
very clever and they're very strong so
it is actually very tricky problem with
many people thought about for a long
time and it's not say it's impossible to
attach something externally to an animal
to to an orangutang but it is not
trivial in any case and I'd love to your
suggestions by the way so yeah there's
all kinds of trade off you know you want
something that's strong but you also
want something that adapts as the animal
that gains weight and loses weight and
there's all these kind of conflicting
trade-offs but very interesting but
that's why actually at the moment what
people uses implants ideally you have
something externally because that's nice
and easy but for the reasons I just
mentioned they use implants
and so these are you know you can see
them here actually forgot to bring some
today but about the size of a 50p coin
but a centimeter thick and they're
implanted at the back of the neck where
the animal has a fatty patch and they
send out a VHF pulse so a little radio
pulse every every one and a half seconds
a very brief pulse that's all it does at
a particular frequency and every animal
operates at a different frequency so
these are implants it's a bit of surgery
was not the end of the world battery
life is you know up to 22 23 years if
you're lucky the problem is it is
surgery so you know it's the animal has
to you have to you know you have to
sedate the animal and then there's a
healing process etc you can't charge the
battery it's very it's actually quite
unreliable for amount of money you pay
for them but okay that's the only
technology there is so okay fine you
have these animals you've got these
implants you put the implant back and
animal you let the animal go in the
forest and then you need to follow him
you need to track the animal to to see
where it's doing so it's a radial pulse
so you have an antenna and you can pick
up you can pick up the pulse when your
antenna so what happens is there's two
people you wander through the bush and
you have your intent you have your
headphones and you kind of wavy and turn
around you listen for beep beep okay and
the animal seems to be there and you
continue the problem is the range you
get is to 300 meters so if you're
further away than to 300 meters you you
don't hear a thing good luck trying to
find the animal if you haven't seen it
for a month and this is you don't really
appreciate it and you until you stand
stood there up to your knees in the mud
and the mosquitoes around your head if
you think you have to go up and down
this for you know some a hill or through
the jungle for literally weeks just
trying to figure out this is the animal
very is quite frustrating so okay that's
ground way so one idea is could we do
this from the air let's not you know
whack our way through the bush can we
somehow you know fly through the air and
then listen for the signals and map out
where the animal is so that was this
project all about so can we use a drone
to fly above the canopy and with a
suitable payload and we can listen for
these radio pings and then we can we can
figure out where the animal is so that
we roughly know its location and then a
ground team can go straight to where
they need to be
and we save a lot of time walking
through the bush waving antennas about
so that's a fundamental problem now this
is you know pros and cons you can drones
are good you know they're relatively
cheap the technology is mature you know
you can't cover thousands of square
kilometers but you can you can cover a
lot more than a human can do walking
around you can use it for multiple
things but of course you know they do
require maintenance they do require some
skill to operate and such but okay it's
a useful trade off then just just the
side note because i get i often get so
fed up with people when you mentioned
this and I I'm doing a talk about this
in a few months time somewhere else and
the the lady who's organizing this talk
she wanted to promote my talk and she
make this big headline no drones and
deep learning saving orangutang you know
the key thing understand here you were
using drones yes but all we're doing is
turning the needle in a haystack problem
to a needle in a bale problem we can
search a larger area but we still have
to search we're not solving the
fundamental problem the fundamental
problem is these implants which only
have a range of 200 meters only have a
battery life of two years there really
needs to be a better solution and
actually actually something a side
project we're kind of exploring how we
can do maybe kind of a sensor network
type approach or we use you know more
sophisticated implant technology or
whatever it's not the be-all end-all
solution it's not going to save wearing
a tank from extinction but for the
particular this particular project and
the partners we're working with that
actually it don't make sense to explore
this the core problem really is habitat
destruction is just people chopping down
forests and there's all kinds of social
issues political issues and the tie into
that it's quite complex and it actually
is pretty depressing if you're actually
there and you see what happens but okay
side note okay so the idea is we want to
start simple so the idea is ok we have
some kind of unknown area we set up a
pre-programmed flight path so you know a
lawnmower pattern should we say and what
we want at the end of some kind of
picture like this where we have ok these
are we have in this case we've detected
four different animals and we know
roughly where they are and we can go
find them that's the idea now the pros
of this is fairly simple and naturally
we can do multiple animals we're just
going to fly a pre-programmed path which
is listen at different frequencies and
see if we hear any beeps
and then we just generate a plot like
that the disadvantages were not very
particularly efficient you could be more
clever and you could say was use a very
directional antenna let's go up let's do
360 try to find a bearing on the signal
zoom in on signal and then continue our
search but this gets more complicated
and complicate is not good definitely
not in the jungle but that's the idea
okay does that kind of make sense drone
fly above the canopy listen for signals
generate heat map so how this so that
was the idea so I spent a lot of time
figuring okay how do we do this and
again starting simple with just off the
self stuff we start with a drone
multi-rotor nothing special just
something where you can mount lots of
things on pics or auto pilot which is a
standard you know one of the more
popular DIY one's pretty good and then
we have so that's the drone itself then
we have the payload we have the
transmitters here which are implanted in
the animal and then we have an antenna
we need to it's an RF it's a radio
signal we need to receive the signal and
then we need something to turn this this
analog signal into a digital samples
should we say we need to sample the
radio signal so we can do some detection
on top of that so this is done with a
software-defined radio which is a fairly
standard thing all it does it you can it
listens for a particular frequency band
and it gives you digital samples of the
radio signal in that band and then we
plug that into a in this case it's an o
droid so just think of it as a Raspberry
Pi but more powerful and then we of
course from Python otherwise I wouldn't
be standing here and we have a little
web app Oh ever are occasions sitting on
top of that so that's kind of the idea
this is sending out pings these two a
mounted on the drone you know you'll
you'll receive the signal through the
antenna you do some processing on the
on-board computer and then you figure
out did I detect an animal or did I not
detect an animal and that's how you fly
about in terms of Python it's nothing
you wouldn't expect so there's a nice
library called drone kit if you want to
interface with with an autopilot and
figure out and know what its GPS
location is or send it Waypoint to etc
nice high level Python library to
interface with the SDR the
software-defined radio is again lovely
library all the processing is you know
the usual scientific Python stack so
numpy sigh primatology dallas is more
for generating some geo Tiff's in in the
process and then actually front end
stuff while all this is served for your
flask and they have lice little high
level web application that through a
browser you can interact with with the
payload and that's just on leaflet react
just because it was convenient so the
whole idea being that you know the
purpose of building the system is
weakened then give it to the charity to
operate which means it has to be able
they have to be able to operate in a
fairly easy seamless way so the idea
being you just have a tablet and you say
look I'm looking for this animal this
animal this animal they're operating
these frequencies please search this
area hit go and the drone goes off and
it searches and does its thing that
that's the idea so you know that was
kind of the stack and when I initially
started this is like okay fine i need to
i have a radio signal so and i can do
Fourier transform and i look at the
frequency spectrum and i can try to look
for spikes in the frequency spectrum
because the spike will mean a pulse
strong pulse so i can do that and i
spend some time looking at this various
way looking the distribution of the
spectrum and it was there an easy way it
can cluster the data into you know where
i have detection zor I don't have
detection before that didn't really
really work out there was no no really
easy way so in the end after lots and
lots of testing the general workflow
that happened they came together is this
so yeah the interactions through the
browser and so the drone takes off and
then it starts flying in a particular
speed a particular altitude and then it
runs through continuous loop what
happens in that loop is you listen for
let's say two seconds you just listen
for a radio signal you listen to second
you collect samples then you take those
samples and you you do a Fourier
transform a look at the spectrum and
then the spectrum you can see is there a
peak in the spectrum there'll be a
picture later and make it clear you look
at the peak and if you detect a strong
peak that means okay there's a
particular pulse and if that pulses at
the frequency of the animal you're
looking for you're probably probably
within range of the ANA now that doesn't
always work so
or while I started off that sometimes
the signal is too faint and you really
can't pick it up from the spectrum so
you can do something in the time domain
as well it's a pulse at a particular
frequency and what you can do is you can
cross-correlate the pulse with the
samples you get and to see if there's a
high correlation and then that gives you
another heuristic for saying okay do I
think there's an animal there or not and
all this happens offline so there's no
communication with the ground the drone
flies around and comes back and tells
you what it's found there's its
heuristic it's not exact there's issues
with not implant is not the exact
frequency it's supposed to be and we
need to operate in real time so as we're
flying about we need to be in real time
collecting everything we can't have gaps
because then we might miss things right
okay I have to be careful conscious of
time so this is the kind of data you get
back you get a spectrum so this is the
frequency you just get the power at each
particular frequency and here and then
you can take this you smooth it a bit
and that's where you get this this is a
tiny wind stuff let's ignore them but
essentially we're looking at this here
and is there a particular spike or pulse
here in this case doesn't seem to be
much going on this is an example of a
detection so here you have a bump in the
frequency spectrum and if you smooth
things out actually you see a very clear
peak so this means yes you know we've
detected an animal that this particular
frequency great you log that with the
GPS could position of the drone and you
can continue so sorry this is this is
linear well and this has just been
normalized so these things don't
actually mean anything is still relative
sorry
so so this is where the heuristics come
in so you know in this case it's it's
very obvious you go one big peak and
lots of small things this one stands out
pretty high it's also given the animal
we're looking for it is roughly in the
right range so I would be looking this
I'd be hundred percent sure that yes
that's a nano of course is this is only
half as big and these ones a bit higher
it's less obvious so this is a great
example but it doesn't always look like
this and so that's why there's there's
quite a few heuristics in there to look
at the size of the peak relative the
others what's the area what's the
magnitude also look at the in relative
terms but also in absolute terms with
the strength of the signal is etc and
there's a combination heuristics that
together you figure out is there
something yes or no are you going to
make mistakes and actually I hope for
the next iteration to do something
Beijing i think was a patient guy here
from last oh yeah i think it makes so
much sense I'd really like a Beijing
approach here anyway conscious of time
because I'm going to get in trouble the
very first thing we tested was just take
a big antenna strap it to a commercially
available drone and just he does this
work do we get into any fear into
interference good does it remotely even
work and actually yeah you know you
collect some data put a few dots on the
map okay it was very very rough but the
principle was proven and so then I spent
yeah pretty much eight months on my
knees in the mud in the in the New
Forest trying this going through
iterations flying and testing and
wondering why stuff wasn't working etc
and then you know the workflow kind of
being take off autonomously I'm just
conscious of time and then it's hard to
see what you see a tiny little dot so
this is starting very easy very low the
transmitters right here the white thing
and then we start slowly at 10 meters
and we go up and down up and down and
then we go progressively higher and this
was done eventually up to 120 meters
height fly up and down and then see at
what point do we stop receiving a signal
what's the maximum height I can fly it
what's the maximum speed I can fly it so
again there's lots and lots of lots of
tests throughout the winter
and then we come back to land and this
but you know the results were
encouraging in that finger just as a
heat map you know we we got the star is
the known location and the heat map is
my heuristic and so we got a nice big
you know red red blob around where the
actual location is so okay things seem
to be working and this you know this
worked ten meters all the way up to 100
meters so okay lots of tests were done I
think okay this seems to be working
however working in UK does not mean
it'll work in Borneo so that was the
idea so then we go to Borneo and then we
started doing the same test there now so
this is the same copter there's an
square antenna strapped to the bottom
which you might see so we take off and
this was filmed with another drone
actually that they had on site so it
worked out quite well where's it gone
Larry so go to a particular altitude and
then fly off and start doing you know
start doing a search pattern and then so
while the thing is flying in just
listening for the radio signals and then
running the Python code on board to kind
of process and figure out is there a
peak yes or no essentially yeah so and
indeed so and this is also first time we
tested with the actual transmitters
implanted and again actually results
were pretty good and there were nice
strong strong peak so but a lot of it
depends on how high you are from the
animal and especially if you got lots of
forest between you that's going to
attenuate the signal etc so there's
while I was getting maybe let's say 100
meters in the UK I was only getting 50
60 meters in Borneo because of the
environmental conditions in the canopy
but ok you know we did lots of tests on
the pre-release site so they were
animals we knew where the location was
and I did spend lots of lots of time
flying up and down different height
speeds generating heat maps and actually
it worked it worked quite well so again
in this particular case you know there's
a very clear red hot spot around where
the actual location is and we verify
that by actually going to the animal and
taking the GPS locations and so that all
worked quite well and so that was in
kind of the second phase
the test we've done it in UK we've done
a testing site in Borneo oh yeah so and
this is actually user interface or is
what I put together is still need lots
of work but the basics were there again
you can tell what free you can tell
which animals you're looking for you're
setting to the radio you do the flight
you come back and you get an interface
like this and you can click on the map
and zooming around you can idea ok where
the animal is so then we went to the
actual release site which was a long
drive and a long hike away through
horrendous conditions but then oh and so
this is the start the actual release
site so once the animals really let go
for good this is where that this is you
know this is where they're released and
so there's a camp in the middle of the
the jungle and so this is where we're
taking off and searching from so in this
case we arrived at the camp and we
wanted to verify that everything worked
so the closest animal was about two
kilometers away so what we're doing here
is we're flying up to a particular
altitude dashing out two kilometers
doing a search pattern and coming back
two kilometers and see do we detect
anything but actually I was doing just
that was already quite tricky because
GPA trying to get a bird GPS look a
canopy was very hard to was very hard to
estimate how our own height in the
height of the animal so to set a proper
flight path and then just the issues of
the heat and the humidity with the the
oh droid cooking itself the voltage
regulator burning through and all these
kinds of issues when you actually try to
do something properly but it and because
of failures in the hardware this was
done completely blind so the thing would
take off it it would go and I would just
have to cross my fingers and hope for it
to come back i had no telemetry
whatsoever so this was a very dense more
tense moment so it's it's it's goes off
and does its thing and then i was very
happy at this point to see come back i
yes it came back and then also became
clear just operating this this kind of
environment is very difficult taking off
is one thing but land
through there so the thing is 100 meters
I was trying to eyeball and trying to
take it down which in this case luckily
was okay but that's also raised issues
in terms of what what drone were using
so so far we've done everything with a
copter just because easy to test with
and you can you know you only need a
small takeoff landing space the problem
is the endurance you get with these
things is nothing so we'd like to go to
a fixed wing but then you need to take
off and landing space we don't really
have takeoff and landings fees so
currently I have somebody working on a
hybrid system so maybe we can take off
vertically and then fly with wings
so I was very relieved when that thing
was back on the ground so it landed and
that we all looked at the data and this
was the recorded video we said okay
looks good and okay how high we I wasn't
sure how much clearance we had with the
trees and we got very excited okay let's
let's drop the heights and what and blew
a larger search pattern and off we went
and then again it took off it flew away
and again waiting there 20 minutes and
then the only telemetry I had was the
transmitter connection that that
triggers again after one sits within a
range of a kilometer so I triggered so I
knew whose about a kilometer away and
then suddenly everything went went dark
so he isn't waiting there like 20 20 20
minutes like home okay maybe you know
maybe it's just the longer search
pattern 25 minutes mm ok let's look half
an hour crack we probably lost the drug
and yeah so it didn't come back we did
then a post-mortem and look to the
topography and things and well because
we lowered the height everywhere we
didn't just lower the height on the the
search pattern what happened was most
likely so it took off it flew two
kilometers they did a search fine went
and it came back but on the last
kilometer back there was a hill with
some pretty high trees where it hit one
of the trees and it's stuck in a tree
somewhere but okay at least we proved
the concept and the data was collected
so anyway so lessons learned from all of
this you know we proved the concept
worked we can get detection zwi can do
an aerial based survey found that if a
can break it will I've seen everything
break and drones get destroying things
it's it's astonishing you actually try
to do something in the real world I also
find if you didn't test it it probably
won't work I just even assume it doesn't
work and if you change something and you
didn't test either it'll hopefully just
not work or it'll break something else
it's a lot of procrastination and and
generally especially operating that
environmental robustness is everything
simplicity and robustness is key much I
prefer that much over having something
that's very efficient and very fancy as
for faced the future so I'm now working
on face to the aim is to go back by the
end of the year with a better system
better drone
and there's in parallels and we're going
out what can we do with the implants
maybe there is some kind of external
attachment not sure and let some
interest from different species as well
ways could be useful and yeah just of
course this has been a lot of my spare
time but you know it's big thank you to
international mountain rescue Britt
Bristol robotics lab has been involved
as well and a whole bunch of other
people and just yeah and just to say you
know I'm a shaky doing this all my spare
time because i think it's an interesting
and front project and this I've learnt a
great deal but um you know if people are
interested in any level hardware
detection Weber whatever talk to me
there's also some really interesting
data the biologists have about the
orangutans how they behave what they
feed on how they move etc that he's just
sitting there unique and so I die this
is just one thing that struck me through
this is when you know you're there you
talk to people and and it's actually
quite depressing if you really think
about the how you manage the natural
environment things as one guy put it
he's a head of one of these large
orangutang projects he essentially said
look conservation is creating hope where
there is none is just it's if you start
to think about it it's just you you know
you think about the bigger picture you
just you know give up and what's the
point but it's really quite shocking um
there's something to think about anyway
thank you very much take insulator on
the data which
create a web of DTM I know I want the
big but it would be 50 by 50 meters
thick of the highest peak and use it to
make sure that you you know give
yourself 10 meters buffer exactly
accurate but it will give you enough
safety to pick up the mountains
excellent exactly so that's that's
something we're considering to do but
also actually for the first fight I had
I had thought about this and I'd ordered
a laser rangefinder and plan to do some
terrain following but because of issues
with ups and mess up on their end it
never arrived on time so I couldn't take
it with me to Borneo and well hey we
lost the drawer well yes something some
kind of terrain following or at least
doing a pre-existing map so you can know
what the height of the trees are is you
really sorry I don't existing oh no no
yeah existing they just really just take
some inside they yeah exactly so that's
for round two yeah this is like this
research is really similar to other if
you look at atomic force microscopy the
way they do breast or scanning so it's
exactly like that if you were still
scanning like that or can you define
research actually is that if you go to
spirals like a Japanese peril can get
more efficient yeah and also something
you can do that could be really
relatable is that like I said you can do
a first scanning of the surface and then
you could use some kind of controller to
put that scanning of the first surface
as the initial data and then on top of
that to just get the valuation on top of
your initial data set hmm I don't maybe
we can talk about it yeah I totally
wasn't aware of that I know about the
flight pattern we've just used lawn
mower skins that's easy and
pre-programmed I did think about spirals
there exactly in so battery wise but in
terms of how to more optimally schedule
fly pavia be interesting to hear
then oh so II mean in the spectrum well
there's when I when I tell this to
people the first thing they say over
that can't work because the drone has
too much interference it'll drown the
signal I found actually for the platform
i was using yes there's noise but it's
you know so that's background noise from
the drone i tried on different platforms
in sometimes you see higher or lower so
that's just the drone producing noise
and you try you have to you know think
how do you mount things and better radio
equipment to mitigate that there's also
just ambient RF noise but of course in
the middle of borneo it's not going to
be too much I think but I don't and
there's just you know the competence i
was using not particularly high spec or
something like the radio's there's some
inherent noise in that so and actually
i'm currently working with an RF
engineering firm to help me to design it
in a better noise resistant way but yeah
if you if you have a radio station
operating close by on the similar
frequency forget it you're going to see
anything you just can see the radio
station
what sorry night I'm flying yes we did
because and also at night the actually I
didn't know orangutang as they build
nest so every night they climb tree top
of the tree in the build a nest and they
sleep there and every night they build a
new nest it was at the top of the tree
so this is great right the top of the
tree there's no canopy you fly over then
the only problem the two problems one
the biologists don't like it because
you're waking up the animal its noise
and etc to actually the transmitter is a
program to only work from 6am to 6pm but
ok you know you so maybe you fly around
4-5 p.m. but then you're disturbing them
making the nest but ok we could get away
with that but that would help yeah
yeah so so definitely a fixed-wing
potentially for endurance at least
potentially solar-powered in terms of
lighter than air so airship the problem
is wind now okay it's on the equator and
actually this very little wind which is
good but still you need quite a big
volume and then launching it recovering
it and you'll get blown about and so
it's not obvious but I did think about
thank you